hey Nick can you do a video about
Lagrange's sure that sounds fun science
asylum is a proud partner with Dollar
Shave Club
hey crazies extreme gravity like you'd
find around black holes it's a lot of
press but you don't have to take gravity
to the extremes for it to do unexpected
things sometimes even Newton's laws are
enough Lagrange's
are one of those times there are five
special points around the orbit of a
planet or moon those lukrons points
orbit with the planet or moon so you can
stick things in there like space probes
and they'll stay it's pretty cool
actually we take advantage of them all
the time well at least the points around
the earth there's a whole list on
Wikipedia they love lists over there but
there's kind of a glaring question here
um why do things stay there and to
answer that we need to delve a little
deeper into Newtonian gravity the
simplest example would be the earth if
some tiny space rock wanders nearby the
earth will exert a force on it which in
turn lets us predict the path that will
take this basically how Newtonian
mechanics works an unbalanced force
causes an interesting motion if there
are no forces or the forces are balanced
the path is just a boring straight line
okay so said a single force from the
earth can only do one of three things it
can speed the rock up slow it down or
make a change direction or any
combination of those that make sense
that's what acceleration is there's
nothing unusual about that it's typical
of any unbalanced force that's pretty
much what Newton's second law says to
get the weird things like Lagrange's we
need two objects exerting a force
simultaneously let's consider the earth
and the moon together this is what they
look like to scale any rock that drifts
into this space is gonna have a force on
it from both but on the line connecting
the earth and moon the forces on the
rock are in opposite directions see
where we're going with this somewhere on
this line the forces should cancel each
other since the moon is less massive
than the earth it should happen closer
to the moon right about here pretty cool
huh
except that's not actually what we want
at first glance that looks like l'orange
number one but it's not the forces on
the rock might be balanced at the moment
but that
last very long because the earth and the
moon are moving through space at
different rates that's highly unstable
Lagrange's at least semi stable so where
did we make a mistake we don't actually
want the force to be zero remember these
points move around as the moon orbits
anything at those points will be
traveling along curved paths curved
paths are accelerated paths and
acceleration means there should be an
unbalanced force so we need to be a
little more careful rather than two
forces adding to zero in Newton's second
law we want them to add to give us
curved motion instead this is the
centripetal or center seeking
acceleration doing that puts the
Lagrange point a bit further from the
moon and a bit closer to the earth this
is LaGrant number one or L 1 for short
it's about 36,000 miles from the moon
compared to the location from earlier
which was only about 24,000 miles you
could use the same technique to find L 2
and L 3 but this isn't very elegant it
requires us to already have some idea of
where they are beforehand and it isn't
very obvious why L 4 and L 5 even exist
there's a better way to do this but we
need to do two things first we need a
change in perspective well we know the
moon orbits the earth this would be a
lot easier if it didn't so let's pretend
like it doesn't can we just do that we
do this kind of thing all the time it's
called a coordinate transformation
rather than having the moon drag all the
Lagrange points around let's imagine our
coordinates are going around in the
opposite direction
it's like rotating our camera with the
moon's orbit to make everything look
stationary the second thing we need to
do is stop talking about forces all
together it's gonna be easier if we do
this in terms of energy instead that
gives us something like this we've got
the gravitational energy from the Earth
from the moon and from the rotation
we're not seeing we should be able to
map it across space and watch though the
grunts just pop out here it is hmm that
isn't so helpful is it oh I know let's
try shading instead of numbers oh okay
that's that's not so hopefully there
maybe if we imagine the energy value as
a height oh I see what the problem is
Lagrange points are really subtle so
we're going
to have to exaggerate things but you
know I think we can still make that last
graphic work imagine you're standing in
the middle of a valley created by a
circular mountain range the first thing
you'd see is this flat ledge if you
place a ball there it'll stay any
deviation from side to side and the ball
will simply roll back to the ledge any
deviation forward or backward and the
ball will roll away down the cliff
that's exactly how l1 works in space any
deviation this direction and the space
rock will return to l1 any deviation the
other way and the rock will fall toward
the earth or moon mathematicians call
that a saddle point and l2 and l3 work
in a similar way in the mountain analogy
you'll find l2 on the slightly higher
ledge behind l1 l3 is directly behind
you so you'll need to pull a 180 again
any deviation side-to-side and the ball
will simply roll back any deviation
forward or backward and the ball will
roll away for that reason these three
points are considered semi statement l4
and l5 are a different story you'll find
those on either side at the highest
peaks the mountains are really flat up
there they're very stable locations wait
wait how can those be stable if the
cliff goes down in all directions yeah
well that's where our analogy breaks
down that's the problem with analogies
they all break down somewhere in space
any motion of the rock will activate the
Coriolis effect that effect makes the
path of the rocks spiral back into l4 or
l5 in our analogy it's as if the motion
of the ball changes the mountain which
sounds a little strange but rotating
frames are weird like that anyway I've
only been using the moon's orbit so I
could draw things to scale the most
useful Lagrange's points are actually on
Earth's orbit around the Sun if you want
a space probe to monitor the Sun we put
it in l1 like Soho if you want it to
always point away from the Sun you put
it at l2 like plunk unfortunately bills
require course corrections every month
or so l3 lasts a bit longer but it's not
much used since it's always blocked by
the Sun it could never send us
information l4 and l5 are so stable they
tend to collect space junk naturally
they don't even need to be related to
the earth
orbit's have these points my favorites
are l4 and l5 for Jupiter they're filled
to the brim with asteroids so what are
the grudge points there are five special
points around the orbit of a planet or
moon they orbit with the planet or moon
so their locations of stability objects
can remain stationary with respect to
the planet remove some of them are fully
stable while others are only semi stable
but the two least stable points are
actually the most useful we regularly
put space probes there for a consistent
view of the universe so what do you
think about lagrangian's
cool not cool let us know in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy we all have our everyday
grooming routines from showering to
brushing our teeth - yes
shaving I don't know about you but I
shower and brush my teeth every day no
matter your routine Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to help you look
feel and smell your best a lot of you've
probably heard of Dollar Shave Club and
think they only stick to shaving
products well don't let the name deceive
you Dollar Shave Club can solve all your
grooming needs in one box shower
products oral care products hair
products skin products blot wipes and
obviously shaving products basically if
you have a body they've got you covered
not only do they ship right to your
house but the more you buy the more you
save they call it their handsome
discounts now's the time to see how
amazing and high-quality their products
are right now they have this great offer
where you can get their shave shower or
oral starter set each for only 5 bucks
they sent me all three of their starter
sets check it out the shave starter set
comes with the executive razor and a 3
ounce tube of their dr. Carver's shave
butter the oral care starter set comes
with their weighty toothbrush and a
trial sized version of their toothpaste
the shower starter set comes with three
trial sized versions of their amber
lavender body cleanser citrus and
Hawaiian ginger face cleanser and sage
and black pepper shampoo join the club
with one of their starter sets for just
$5 after that the restock box ships with
regular sized products at a regular
price get this exclusive deal at
dollarshaveclub.com slash science asylum
today the featured comment comes from
Michaela who said
it doesn't matter if reality is discrete
or not because all numbers are just
abstract ideas I like this approach
because it means the answer doesn't have
to be open-ended yes pie exists because
all numbers exist in our minds and our
minds exist I think anyway thanks for
watching